hello all i can think better to get with
the bound scatman you know what that is
that's the remnants of extra life 2015
where I couldn't use my voice properly
and it still hasn't gotten back I've
slept for 24 hours hello wasn't the
lobby okay swats weekly hangar at every
tuesday at two p.m. pacific right here
on gamespot com I'm Don your Dwyer hi
how you doing you doing good we've got
video games to talk about Aaron Samson's
here Ashley scatters here from cnet com
how you doing I'm great I'm excited
you're in town today in town yeah I am
in town for a little bit and then I'm
doing some stuff video stuff with you
guys and then that I get to go back to
LA for more tomorrow daily how's the El
Nino happened in LA I know there's a
maybe like one storm okay I say put up
or shut up el nino yeah like I mean
either get it get to it or get out you
got flood insurance nope nope yeah but
you are its water and I mean you live in
the part of the bay area where the Apes
were eventually gonna take over I mean
there's like fizz yeah so that happened
playing the age I'm waiting for a thanks
for that reminder yeah just I'm not
afraid of apes you know murdering my
whole family um yeah it's got a hat
Marin baby thanks for that monkey
tan-tan who cares anyway we're here to
talk about fallout 4 as it happens I
spend a couple of hours last night I
needed like some time away from the
wasteland so I went back to sanctuary
and I started just doing up my house i
made like a locker from my clothes and
for my weapons and the bobblehead holder
which is only got two bobbleheads it out
of like 30 holders and it was nice and
relaxing i'm both of you guys have also
been putting a lot of time into digging
up your base as well yeah i am i've
renamed the game Fallout 4 happy home
designer okay I have this problem where
I ruin open world games and so this time
I as opposed to the other open world
games that I've found ways to get
distracted in this I got really into
settlement building and I still early in
the game because I didn't get mine early
i got my pit boyish anon friday cool
only had a couple days to play before I
flew up here but but yeah I finished the
first part of the you know the original
main storyline quest where you meet
Preston any death blow yeah I kill your
desk log I get your Dethklok
then and then you get back up to
sanctuary and then I started
transferring everything because I'd kind
of planted everything at at rockit as
opposed to sanctuary so I was like oh
not gonna drag her thing you got to
sleep your home my listen dog meat
you're gonna be carrying a lot of stuff
so I loaded up dog me and I came back up
the sanctuary and then I started got to
work and now everyone's got it's got a
nice bed mm-hmm I've been taken down a
bunch of houses and stuff but honestly
like it's it's a really interesting I
find the settlement building really
interesting and fall out yeah when it's
when we first got our hands on a couple
of weeks ago Aaron was you decided to
put together a sort of a base building
guide and for a while they were kind of
just trying to figure out like what is
this for exactly it took a while I think
I started getting a grasp of what the
base buildings higher purposes and it
took about a week and a half of actually
base building and digging through the
guide and to be honest it's one of those
features where it's a lot of fun and you
can level up and waste a ton of time but
it's totally optional mmm it mostly has
to do with the high level crafting in
the game and having places to put your
cool crafting stations so you can you
know you know build a garden and then
have a spit and roast up some stuff to
make guns at the 80 adhesives yeah and
or use a chemistry station to make oil
so it seems like at the higher level the
bases are for fun and then therefore
high level crafting yeah hailing your
rads i mean i like that was the big
thing that i find myself going back for
making sure i have like purified water
of course get back there you got your
you like being able to you know instead
of using rat away which is a little bit
rare it seemed to me so far it's been a
little bit rarer than in previous vlog
games so I really like that you know you
can just go back and heal up and kind of
take a break I think the cooking stuff
we're chip sitting out of New Vegas and
has definitely been explored a lot in
this it's really good as well because
like when you're adding like making like
steaks out of death claws and mole rats
and everything like they heal you almost
as much as stems like you can real as
long as you're not playing survival mode
you can really like town on those and
and you get your help and if you cook it
you don't take the radiation hit which
is really nice yeah which is a mess of
you know we go on a stick like before
you you take it but it was like oh it's
like limiting one this one it limits
your maximum health rights also there's
some weapons later in the game like this
r injure where you have a craft all the
mo for yes so yeah shell Scott that is
pretty crazy it's funny to like when you
build a nice base you should probably
start every day in the wasteland by
taking a nice nap if you take an eight
hour nap particularly if you have a
romantic partner there hmm um you get an
XP boost its like ten percent for the
purse oh wow I don't know how long it is
when you go out in the waste processing
power yeah 45 minutes hour or something
like that the thing I've been doing as
well as I don't know like in previous
games the worlds of you know the capital
wasteland and new vegas or stuff are
always so like scary and intimidating
and awful and after a mission you kind
of go back to somebody and sell that
stuff you don't need and you feel a
little bit more like safe when you're in
a when you're in a like a hob town where
is what i'm doing in this now is I'm
actually I'm finding sanctuary in
sanctuary like I'm i'm going out into
the world and i'm collecting more stuff
that ideally just sell and just kind of
bring it at home I like storing it I did
that in fallout 3 and when I ruined
fallout 3 so I got to the very first
like the area of how homes before you
even get to make a ton i found the lay
the first lady you meet where she's like
real twitchy and jumpy and i was just
like well I don't like this lace so I
killed her and then I took over her
house and and then I ended up just I was
like well I'm gonna clean up the
apocalypse and so I just took every when
I got to the supermart that was a real
problem that was a real problems like yo
see more days to clean out yeah I was
it's so it's so much like that were all
I wanted to do is just like pick up
every bit of garbage and now it's even
better because now I can scavenge and
break down stuff for crafting so it's
like you know oh this house is this
ruined house well that's I'm gonna scrap
it hey exhale mandate I love scrapping
it's great and then you know you'll fill
your room with cat posters so you feel I
know I know those mountains heads I've
now gone on in the sitting room and then
yesterday I was putting up some lighting
in my cuz I've gone back to my house
like the house my character OG house
yeah I put up a lights i leveled up to
20 because i like put up like a rotating
fan and i've been doing so much of that
stuff over there like previous errors
that what we're seeing if you if you
combine it with idiot savant they're
like earlier were so great the less
intelligent you are the more likely you
are to have a huge boost and you start
building you can get it to trigger
fairly frequently
crafting anything you do like just
random XP just happens it's pretty
pretty great so but you have to get like
yeah do you have to have a little more
low intelligence which I think for me
like I preferred a little bit more so I
like I kind of want to start a second
save okay like I want to play very
differently twice so but of course you
know that I'll be dead before that's
that happens before I finished two games
fallout 4 apparently there's a cuz I
yesterday I spent like a good 20 minutes
taking I haven't drunk any nuka-cola
because i remember in the previous game
it was like never nerd is it nirn roush
in oblivion and Skyrim was that stuff
that you collected it's always a
question about like collect 10 of this
sat it to this vendor for like loads of
money there was one in I think for three
or maybe it was bad on new Vegas about
nuka-cola quantum and it was not a
person we're like giving him nuka-cola
was always beneficial swine ever I've
like been trained never to drink of
Saveur so I put them all on my fridge
would like to do so meant like picking
them up in the game and then trying to
get them it but apparently if you're in
builder mode they straight up just
stunned Oh like they stand up on the
wrong that's a pro tip I found out that
you can you can actually like I went
around in fifth this again like guys I
have a real I'm a real open real gaming
problem I spent like three hours on
Sunday night just walking around fixing
fences oh thank you hurry I was like oh
man these fences I gotta fix I don't
like looking at them there's some of the
fences are down some of them are up so
then but if you're in build remote it
they all snap together really nicely
door snap in room everything snaps in
really great and I'm like offices this
is gonna be good yeah the one no broken
windows inside as long as you start with
the foundation block that's the one
trick is like you cannot build on Hills
very well unless you put in the
foundation concrete blocks and they will
level your base out and tell me the bet
about the advanced defense stuff cuz i
know you've dipped into that iron so
defenses are kind of funny i put a lot
of defenses up initially and then my
base never got attacked yeah I couldn't
fair what was happening so it says that
if you read through the guide it says
that the higher your defense rating the
less likely you are to be attacking Roy
so you may not you may never be attacked
if your defense rating is really hot
interesting and also i haven't seen
people wander into the confines of the
bases so i think they'll only start
attacking small settlements or
settlements that you've built to the
outskirts up right and they'll aggro on
things again
audio yeah yeah so my my impression of
that was you just put up a couple
defenses as long as your rating is as
high as your population or higher it's
not likely it'll ever happen did you put
in some of that crazy stuff with the
terminals in the lazy yeah so at high
level there's some fun stuff you got to
get a couple of the perks going but so
in order to do an advanced trap you have
to build a laser trip wire and you hook
that up to like a flamethrower and then
all that has to be hooked up to power
and a terminal okay and you tell the
terminal don't kill people I love or
like people will just walked in to find
Carla walks through you got to make sure
if the flavors are good turned out but
again later nobody's attacked my base
really so I don't it's kind of a bummer
yeah like you kind of you cuz people
really build up those defenses they're
hoping people come attack them right
like that's the thing you want you're
like oh man I want to see all these
crazy home alone traps go on when the
Raiders come and then like they just
never show up maybe shows a bummer maybe
like that you just do at home alone so I
like build a really weak base yeah with
like one person in a Brahmin and then
like I would join up with defense then
just to see what happens that seems like
it would be really fun come back and
collect the corpses so maybe you can
pull a walking dead and like kite a
bunch of raiders all the way to a base
like could you do it may be a few kite
stuff maybe you could you could test it
out and lastly guys obviously have put
so much time into your various bases
what is a favorite thing you've gotten
your base right now what is your pride
and joy in your base Aaron Samson watch
it I pride and joy I you know it's it
was just building hi like I'm still
going okay I got to about four stories
and I thought that was the limit but
then I was reading through the guide and
I saw lighthouse with like it was
alright somebody put they had like a six
or seven or eight story structure so my
goal right now is just to build a
medieval tower as high as possible nice
I haven't done it yet but it's gonna
happen squad by go oh yeah let's cruise
really nice Jeanne that's what you'd is
our you built yeah this there's there's
no physics like you won't fall over if
it's not properly but restore something
else who needs physics is ridiculous
what about yourself function uh for me I
it's early so I feel like I'm gonna have
new favorites because I'm early
and but I think for right now I like is
it really dumb if I say like I'm really
impressed with my fence rebuilding no
that's all right I actually like I
really like having nice organized stuff
so it's been great to actually
reorganize all of the different yards
and it's like I said people everyone I
ever wanted and watching this is
probably like this broad needs a
straitjacket like finder one in the
wasteland but yeah I really like and
also I I'm really proud of the fact that
really really early i was able to build
out the what is it the signal that
brings in oh yeah don't see no signal
beacons where people can come in and
stuff and and I I'm really i think my
favorite thing of just settlement
building actually is the really nice
quest line that I've been doing with
Preston so going out to the other
settlements isn't really good it's
enjoyable let's go well I'm happy with
my little trunk full of grog knock the
Barbarian all my magazines and stuff
just hit a nice day I'm waiting for
someone to steal it in your fridge
nuka-cola I'm a fridge in nuka-cola but
I have to order organ did you write your
name on it by the way cuz the settlers
you can write your name on so I mean
like I'm just saying those settlers
might see it oh yeah thank you again
yeah I keep going into the house is like
trash on Carla or someone's to sit and I
now I'm like good supposedly they can
pick stuff up if you just leave some
yeah thanks i can pick and pick it up so
be careful all right you're a little got
game up against the post it man yeah
perfect defense system flamethrowers yes
exactly then tell it to shoot a funny
buddy yeah especially anyone touching my
nuka-cola aaron actually thank you so
much for coming on let us know what you
think of the base building of 404 have
you built any cooler base yourself leave
your thoughts in the comments below
we'll be back in the second folks we've
got a bunch more chat we got zener
brooke Xenoblade Chronicles I'll peter
brown man you guys got to explain to me
what the hell this game was all about
you've been playing it for a whole week
we'll get my can draw bonds talking
about from pretty soon after that but
first of all here's a trader for the
crew wild run
what brings me out here it's the
adrenaline rush
i'll raise anyone and
because nothing needs to feel crossing
the road first
all roads lead
more adventures
this world is just waiting to be seen
I'm joining a family
everywhere is my playground and I get to
use all my
and you what brings you out here
Xenoblade Chronicles X let's all do it
it actually knots cross cross cross I
missile it works try to cross the power
of Christ compels you to play this video
game which came out in Europe back in
April no Japan mad sorry japan by april
and it's coming out and this month or
december third awesome when's our of you
gonna be up november 30th awesome but
you guys have been playing the game for
a little while and we're gonna ask you
without getting into the sort of
critical assessment area and all about
this game so for those who don't know
zen abate chronicles as a series i guess
what is cross exactly so Xenoblade
Chronicles X cross everyone i pronounced
it is like kind of a pseudo follow-up to
the the wii title Xenoblade Chronicles
they share some similarities in terms of
mechanics but in terms of the world
everything like that very different
games and it takes place in a very big
world this new one people liken it to
bigger than the witcher Skyrim and
fallout combined yeah yeah and a truly
open world like it's one of these things
where if you look somewhere you can go
see it you can go there right pretty
much if you can figure out a way to jump
all the way up onto something and you
can pretty much climb anything yeah or
swim or summer swim too yeah excellent
it's huge it's really big tell us about
the world it's on earth Earth's been
gone blowing up to your crotch lon this
stuff man yeah sorry my voice is a
little weird to case people are
wondering why anyway so you yeah the
spaceship left Earth and then got in the
middle of an alien con flat conflict
crash landed on this planet and and
you're sort of their scouting the planet
just to figure out how to make a life
for everyone who is part of New Los
Angeles which is a section of the
massive space ship that can we just
destroyed old Los Angeles why would you
make a new one yeah of all the cities um
yeah where's yeah no no that's they just
left effects i think new los angeles is
not yeah sicily name um but yeah this is
so this this is the map and all those
little towers are like you go when you
put down a probe which means you've
effectively
colonized or surveyed that area okay so
what you're doing is you're colonizing
this world and you're collecting samples
picking up remnants the whole big thing
is like you are part of a group of
people that is that are trying to find
the rest of the people like everyone
else is in like cryostasis or something
yeah the ship exploded right so it's
like all over the planet there's some
there's some people that are in
cryostasis so you have to go find them
and that yeah that's totally part of it
the no one cool thing this game does
though right like you explore as part of
the story like for quests but as you lay
down those probes as Alexa was
describing their those actually play a
bigger picture in terms of like loot and
stuff like that so you can set these
probes two different things one of the
things they can do is mine hmm as you
mind and collect this resource believe
it's called mourinho yeah yeah what you
then do is you can use that to invest in
different weapons and armor
manufacturers and get access to new loot
so the more you explore the more ability
you have to unlock new gear not just by
finding it what you do but also by
investing in companies who develop new
stuff what they're showing right now on
the screen are the mechs got da and the
Japanese version they were called dolls
now they're called skills because
because you know whatever um and also
play with dolls right and these are a
really big part of the game but they
don't I'm about 25 hours in and okay and
I think I'm close to the point where
maybe I'm going to unlock them right so
this is a game which is pushing the like
70-80 aramark yeah it's a very big game
and I kind of liken it to an MMO it
doesn't play like an MMO but what it
does do is offer a huge amount of quests
and sometimes these are easy to find
excuse me other times like Xenoblade
Chronicles on the wii u have to find
people in a specific part of town at a
specific time of day and have talked to
someone else oh wow like very specific
all right let's give you respite for a
sec Alexa tell me about the question is
like main quest stuff this affinity
quest which are about getting sort of
extra people on your team or yeah
there's just so much crap to deal with
in this game and I both love it and hate
it there's a you so
you pick which you pick a job there's
like I think it's 7-10 something like
that different job classes and they have
different things like okay you're going
to focus on colonizing new areas you're
going to focus on finding people that
are in cryostasis or you're going to
focus on killing big animals and you
join that group and then you have a
separate level of whatever you're doing
in that group and then you have your
personal level then you have your
affinity levels and then you have your
field level don't forget your blade
levels yeah your plate level here
whatever job you have and then you have
your field level and there's your
archaeological skills your mechanical
skills and your something biological
skills and all of these level up
separately but together and sometimes
you can't do something if a certain
level isn't high enough because you need
to get another level high enough you
can't level up that a lot of lighthouses
level that person management character
management quest management it's I'd say
quest management world management if you
if you play it intelligently when you
figure out how everything ties together
it actually works pretty smoothly across
the board like you understand how one
thing affects another and so on it's a
little bit difficult to understand at
first read the manual get my advice to
you know the games coming manuals
anymore what uh this we don't have the
retail like physical version of this
game we have the disc but the in-game
manual okay where you find it and it's
very helpful actually eyes yeah um or
you could play it dumbly like me I
refuse to read the manual I'm trying to
figure out all that on my own yeah and
it is it's so much to take in I mean I
like really thick meaty JRPGs but this
is a JRPG ass junior it's crazy it looks
good tell us all about the worlds the
idea of an open sort of planet where you
can travel anywhere is seems very
appealing to me at tell me about the
world in its inhabitant since monsters
and people you so the world again is
huge and it is pretty much wilderness
you will maybe encounter some you know
organic I don't I don't wanna spoil
anything anyway so yeah anything big
wide world with a huge scale like big
mountains big cliffs big animals big
bodies of water saving animals it's huge
and and at times it's it's really
impressive at least to me and it's not
one of those games where the world is
big but it's not interesting like the
way the landscaped is is shaped and the
way things
sort of interplay like the water with
the mountains and stuff it's actually
done really well if there was a lot of
attention to detail to give these places
a unique feel beyond just this has sand
versus grass and so on and it yeah and
it's really big and you can pretty much
go anywhere I think there are some
contents that are disconnected that
maybe you need the scale to get to I'm
not positive yeah I mean you're able to
wander into areas like one she was
telling me about place called oblivia
it's sort of connected to the first
content you start on but when you first
get there at least when I did there were
lightning storms mm-hm and I was slowly
having my health depleted and it was
like the hell apparently you need to
have a lightning sort of debuff thing
but at the same time if you wait the
time of day changes the weather changes
the weather changes and you can go in
there just fine so it's it's a massive
living world and there are creatures
that will always be agro always out to
get you there are legendary versions of
creatures always be Agra ya know if you
grow and you have creatures that are
just huge monstrosities it's like you
know Bulbasaur the elder level like 93
or something they difficult fights uh
lots of difficult fights it's easy to
kind of get yourself caught in a line of
sight of an enemy that's too high level
alright so part of this game is being
aware of your environment as well and
traversing it carefully in doing so and
and yeah I'm really liking the loop
right now of questing and getting loot
and in leveling up so that's been great
I've liked that a lot cool does it feel
I have you played previous games in
series Alexa yeah yeah I played the hell
out of xenoblade chronicles the last one
yeah that was really great does it feel
like very similar to it yeah cuz it has
like the art system which is I guess
like the spells and the different
attacks like it's a very similar combat
system but everything else is just like
it would be different the quest
structures is similar the thing I was
describing earlier with like the way I
fitting emissions work you know like
getting to know people and doing that
sort of thing it's really there for the
hardcore folks because yeah fans of the
genre yeah yeah can you play this not as
a hardcore is it a blade fan yeah I mean
this is only the second game in the
series and it's not really connected to
the prior one beyond mechanics um
gameplay just as a non hardcore video
game fan because this seems like it's
the type of game that requires quite a
lot of you
of time commitment and yeah this is
definitely a video games mins video game
against great law honestly read the
manual like that's just my advice like
we're doughnut struggle or don't
struggle but that's the choice you're
deciding to make on your own okay I'm
playing it dumbly as opposed to in
Dillon you should do like a to take
review on this one the manual versus the
not my gosh I'm still running in like
Kofi Morkel vs education is a 70-200 our
game what we've heard so excellent ends
a lot of time under review will be off
last day of this month last day this
month awesome yeah thanks so much guys
coming on and explaining to me the
terrified as if there wasn't you know I
I just have all this free time there's
not enough open world games out there
not get out this year right 2015 my
goodness and maybe one to get in your
Christmas stocking let us know if you
are going to pick it up later this year
or if you're already in Japan and you're
just halfway through at this stage in
the comment box below we'll be back in a
sec we've gotta talk to all those dudes
but Battlefront it's at today officially
even though most of us in playing all
weekend thank you yay access but first
of all let's check out a trailer for
deadpool's back Deadpool Deadpool
surprise universe it's me Deadpool
marble antihero extraordinaire this is
my launch trailer and research shows
that trailers dubstep and absolute chaos
go together like Wolverine and bad
haircuts oh yes dubstep the dulcet tones
of a computer being lobotomized that
make kids go wild that being said drop
the beat babe
I love games
now it's like tacos you like tacos Wade
silence fool
did somebody get a microphone because
this would be a perfect time to wrap it
pink bear study
hello welcome back to gamespot com the
website were three white dudes wearing
blue shirts or cross their legs in the
exact same manner I'm wearing red sox
who you are you're wearing red socks
you're also going to blue shirts Aparri
Marty flexible I'm wearing two blue
shirts but my real intention was to do
this do that duh Star Wars man Star Wars
how appropriate ah Star Wars bought from
Ted today officially you reviewed it yep
when did your of you go up last night
and nine that's funny cuz i was playing
it oh yeah yeah ah da access yeah xsy
was like 10 hours yeah 10 hours yeah
yeah so like yeah we got I was playing
it like a retail copy and then it was I
completely forgot that like EA access
would have like there would be a drop
off before it actually released so I was
wondering why it's like this seems
really kind of unpopulated I suppose the
last four days yeah but yeah Robbins now
you were playing a bunch last week you
in Crested a massive stream on this
couch six hours last week first of all
before I asked Mike way gave it 7 out of
10 what do you think of star wars
battlefront does a fan of like
first-person shooter games and massive
star wars huge fan of battlefield huge
Star Wars fan so you think those would
coincide pretty well and they do you
know it's just how long will I will I be
enjoying it yeah i'm currently enjoying
it still love it I mean it still has
these it still retains these moments
where you know at I Fire will come out
of sky blow up right in front of you and
it sounds and looks spectacular it is
eye candy up the wazoo and i love it and
i still get those highs like in these
moments right but we were talking about
it and they kind of start drifting off
alright and you know there's i'm gonna
let him talk about the progression and
how the longevity just simply is not
doesn't that seems like the problem
right because it looks it looks and
sounds even if someone who's not a
massive star respond super legit like
it's it's the way you want to star wars
games to look and said if you're a fan
but it just it's not the depth isn't
there right right because there's nine
game modes and each of them are
pretty different I mean the my favorite
to our supremacy and Walker assault walk
ourselves the well they're really
telling them and you see someone's
beating the [ __ ] out Vader um Walker
Saul is the most the the one where you
actually that's like their unique one
we're kind of attack and defend almost
but then it's they're actually using
those iconic you know the 8080 is coming
at you and the it used to be pretty
imbalance in the beta but now it's my
favorite mode they do join things to
make it like even better for the rebels
and everything what are the types of
modes supremacy which is kinda like a
tug of war zone capture then they have a
droid run which is like domination but
it's the droid so they wander around the
map so there's no static pointing to
Hill King yeah it's like yeah king of
the hill almost and then you know they
have Fighter Squadron which is all viet
just vehicles airborne like ships and
then you have just like the classics
cargo is pretty much capture the flag
which is it's fun but it's not too new
or anything but the thing is like
despite how many gay modes there are
none of them get too deep walker salt i
love and i still want to keep playing it
but everything else like fighter
squadron right here you see you feel
like you've seen everything after about
an hour in each one sure like like
towards the end I'm I'm just sticking to
supremacy and Walker so um that's are
like the big modes right it's the big
modes where you get you get to the
entire experience that you want you what
you want everything for the most part
but you know you get these kind of these
these half ass foes my opinion you know
like a hero hunt where it's just not
thought out where it's you you take
turns becoming the hero so I played a
couple times this mode and the idea is
that it's it's one team and yet if you
if I if I'm the last guy to if I kill
hero and i become the hero and then i
could rain terror it's basically a
free-for-all with team play trying like
else because everyone for themselves but
they're all shooting the same thing yeah
edward what happens is like yeah i
wasn't it i like their couple rounds i
could not kill the hero because you
he'll kill me seconds away from him
dying that someone else comes in swoops
in the kills like glass hit yeah exactly
and it's it was frustrating and i like
that was it bad was i have no interest
applying that again here's Palpatine
doing barrel rolls haha you know just
like a weird see that's yeah and II
liked how they shop out teen's death in
their game
they're like why is everyone still
fighting wars over we've won yeah yeah
is the problem that it's like what even
with all this variety game owes the game
itself like in terms of you controlling
our character is super basic like you
you have one bucket of shoes you pick up
power-ups that are sort of floating
around the world it's not like something
like battlefield for instance where
you're loading at a character with like
four different things right yeah because
that's I mean you could say a lot of
online multiplayer can be repetitive hmm
but in this like you play halo not to
compare the two but you have halos
momentum on combat so fun and it can
unfold differently each way there's a
lot of emergent gameplay yeah in this
the vast majority of firefights it comes
down and I mention this in the review
it'll come down to two people see each
other and you'll start just you'll push
the trigger and hold it and depending on
how slightly better you're a might be
exactly the one that walks away exactly
and the blasters this feeds into this is
kind of a problem with a progression
system as well a lot of the blasters
aside from one being automatic the next
being you know semi the next being kind
of a shotgun in a way they're all very
similar so you feel like you're just
kind of playing the same way over and
over like the modes are changing how you
play and the good modes really can lead
to some of that emergence stuff but by
and large it just after about after a
while playing anything especially a team
deathmatch I just I don't want to go
back to those is it wrong to threat
whatever Isaac updates six hours in
total I never upgraded my blaster cuz oh
yeah I bought a new one yeah it felt
fine to me yeah like there was nothing
about it that I felt or maybe like less
recoil yes that's what it really is its
recoil I just started going like
pressing pressing pressing instead of
holding it down right as to compensate
yeah I mean that's the thing and that's
like the only like I would have loved to
have seen types of progression in like
vehicles right like hmm like what I
loved about I mean I have to prepare to
like battlefield 3 and 4 is like cool
I'm gonna I'm just gonna fly and we're
gonna do is I'm gonna upgrade my weapons
on this on this crap I'm gonna get
better photon torpedoes whatever you
want to do it there isn't anything like
that like it's just simply this infantry
it's really if a tree base right and
like you know you're flying around you
get shot down pretty quick but you're
not you're not really present and yeah
the most part not as much
you'd like to be you like you'd like to
have some involvement you know some chat
would be nice like hey we need air
support you know like it's missing it
finds its it sounds like the bottle is
just sort of happening and you
you're-you're there rather than really
you know impacting it right it feels
much more like you're spectating in a
way and then you happen to come across
these old firefights but I never really
aside from a few times Walker assault
and supremacy I never felt like I was
really impacting the battle if I was
doing really well and getting a few
kills without dying which this games
pretty hard to not die in because again
it's just these exchanging laser like
exchanging blaster fire and everything
and yeah it's it doesn't ever feel like
I had a clear sense of what was I mean I
knew what we're supposed to be doing but
I wasn't sure how it was going aside
from you know the kill counter at the
top yeah kind of an indication but I
never really felt like I was like okay
I'm gonna get on the speeder bike I'm
gonna go to their back outpost gonna
take and then I'm gonna come help my
buddies at this one it was always just
I'll just see what happens it's just
chaos because then that's the thing to
write is you have these power weapons
and options on the field but you aren't
picking them yeah you're just giving
them so if you are if I died like okay
well let me let me handle this
differently let me get a rocket launcher
and take out a that a TST know you got
first off you gotta find this icon cross
your fingers maybe I'll get a rock lunch
or no you get a dome you get a dome
shield your way great and you burn that
and then you try to find another one
it's just there's no yeah it's just
chaos yeah you like to you know find a
way like a play style I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna pay buddy you know let's take
out this thing like that's all agency in
the bottle yeah it's weird you say her
because I was at once a is trying to
like rush to stop them taking an
objective and I ran into one of the like
tie fighter like pickups and I was like
well I was actually going to help over
here but like I have to pick this they
go but have a go is he actually kind of
[ __ ] it that strategy I had right on
the other side of that and that has this
is actually I found really weird is
there's one icon that you pick up that
basically if I had a burn card like the
ion shot the idea is that yes you see in
the bottom right there and then it's
like a kinda like a recycling sign when
I throw that i use the iron shot i can
throw this on in
recharge quicker hmm but had this issue
were in the earlier phases of the game
you don't get a burn card you have to
work for it to like from like 125 or
something that so I pick up this icon I
can't get rid of it because I'm no but
alright yeah I go to the swing I'm like
I can't get this i can't think how do
they have the stupid burger you cannot
get rid of it yeah the only ones i think
you can swap out in certain cases a hero
ones but you come across those yeah
that's a nightmare another one is like
it's just these issues like oh cool
there's an x-wing bro down the mountain
Luke's helping us know about now there's
no time it's like oh there's an x-wing
down over here but there are 80 s T's
and troops surrounding it and it's down
the movin out in the open yours like all
right I will die but I'm gonna make an
effort because I'd like to fly an x-wing
you never know so it sounds like a good
game a great guy very fun at first but
it's just a limited Brisbane honest as
it can be you're still gonna come across
those moments in the first ten I was
your like I'm Luke Skywalker I just cut
an eight EST in half it might have
stomped on me afterwards but in order to
do it off a cliff yeah that that was
create in to this high fighter or you
did one yeah cuz there's that there's
that gift for the Luke Skywalker force
pushing someone into a TIE fighter as it
flies by the craziest thing I've done
and tay doesn't believe me i need to
actually go back and find the footage on
my ps4 at home i was standing on a cliff
on Hoth and han Solo has this really
ridiculous shoulder charge yeah it's fun
to do but it's kind of dumb in a great
way but a TIE fighter was flying by like
trying to just shoot me in the face and
all the sudden to pull out of the last
second but i did my shoulder charge and
it must have been like oh hell no way
i'll bring it in well i'll i'll find
some i'll find it maybe you dreamt that
yeah it was great and it blew up fun
last question it looks pretty good on
consoles and guys seen it on pc yet i've
been playing at pc look right now and it
looks really good yeah we're trying to
get it to run a 4k with lectern out some
settings at UK it's like already do all
right I have to say also is you know as
someone who loves Star Wars what I am
looking forward to with this game is I
think I just found out today or we get
the other days they kind of released a
statement that they're gonna have all
this DLC and it's like some like 16 maps
yes or no you have shocked ooh that's
coming
vasken so that I think they're releasing
it like by like jock who obviously is
gonna have more than one map on it right
so I'm not sure how many but its total
they're planning alright alright so more
planets now and then most of the each
game mode on each map has its own like
variant of the map so there's a bunch of
maps cool but I'm kind of looking for I
mean exactly and so it's gonna be cool
to at least I mean you know you these
these DLC packages are gonna come out
and you'll be like cool let's try it out
a couple hours All Right see you later
everything that's how it's gonna go but
I am a little curious to see how these
gonna look right yeah cuz I I I imagine
they're also going to be really similar
to the movie you know juku is a is a
battle that happened like I maybe it'll
pull on that a lot and so see you
haven't you were pretty interesting
awesome good fan service of Star Wars
fence like very much adobe a some
gameplay up on games what I calm later
on today yeah awesome all right let us
know what you think of Star Wars
Battlefront are you a star respond or
about him fan are you excited or
disappointed they leave your thoughts in
the comment box below alright we're
almost done we got to give away all this
nonsense look at this box of nonsense we
have 0 star wars star wars awesomeness
we have everyone's favorite right there
Darth Maul look at it all moreover the
chair gets on these things that add to
win this big old box of Star Wars
goodies and make sure you follow
gamespot on twitter and retweet the
tweet lets up on your screen right now
look it's that is that the same picture
of Mary we just keep photoshopping
different things and we got lucky god we
got loop and chewy look it's looping
soon I didn't know what that is hold it
up Mike just go e lubin julio's that so
often okay oh that's adorable Bobby you
are not good at hop it we got Disney
infinity 3.0 characters here as well we
got obi-wan Kenobi that's the starter
pack stop there's so much stuff oh you
think you're dumb we've got Star Wars
catchphrase look at that Tom Luke is
Kyle let's do a catchphrase okay
batteries not included ought to win all
this stuff as you said make sure you it
says powered by Duracell right in front
right there I don't know maybe it's
someone else will probably throw in some
batteries and make sure we turn it
sabbatical
what's Lupin to you bet I don't know
join Chewbacca and take down those
stormtroopers according to look sort of
like a like Hungry Hungry Hippos okay
hungry hungry hippo okay probably
nothing like that don't listen to me but
it looks kind of like less like a board
game more like okay happy these kids are
ya having a great time they've also
mountainous to all turn up in different
colored shirts it would be good
advertising if they're really sad it
wouldn't no no I wouldn't want to buy
that no I wouldn't buy it there in the
back of the box there you go you can win
all this stuff make sure you eat sweet
case fun makes you following us on
tweets own whoa whoa whoa loop in Chile
whoa it's doing loops even right now Oh
Mike sick Mike don't get your sickness
on this a child okay with it p stop I
feel fine p on the gifts drink power see
this morning to have a person ah Rob
yeah what are you doing this week on the
video games like uh doing some
battlefront and then I think I'm gonna
do some probably some fallout layer in
the week lepida gum I did a a feature
today on the junkjet you did yeah those
various those realize the hoarders
juncture but it was good as good but yet
fallout I mean I'm actually we're doing
right now is I'm playing on pc so I have
to make up for the 20 hours i did on
xbox but like it's it it was worth it
I've been playing on PC it's so much
just smoother like it looks great i
actually have only like a 680 i can
crank it up really want a different
general direction have an entirely
different experience no game i'm
surprised that well it runs on like
normal guards yeah i was i was afraid i
was afraid i needed to like super place
my system but no I'm doing good looks we
got 60 frames second Mike what are you
up to um now that I put about 25 hours
into battle front I'm gonna I beat Metal
Gear Solid the other night finally which
the real ending so every every day I
come in Pete Browns like did you did you
beat house like well i'm on chapter 2
the whole thing I no spoiler free
there's like you know that later late
game stuff and I was like I came in
today I like PETA beat it yeah and then
apparently there's this one mission i
still haven't done that you can do so
i'll do that tonight and then yeah
fallout i've been putting off have like
another review coming up but fall out
what's that review can you say i don't
know i think so I mean it's one of the
December second releases you can narrow
it down what is two games on the
summer sex Just Cause 3 and what's the
other one Rainbow six siege okay oh
there you go so i will be reviewing one
of those will you be mostly doing first
person shooting or will you be mostly
jumping around a tropical island its
first person shooting if you zoom out
over the shoulder and just have a
grappling hook and yeah all right good
looking for today that's how I would
describe the game so many games coming
out or how come it this year great ones
and more on the way we got a bunch of
crazy game of the year stuff coming up
at the end of the air will actually be
doing a bunch of it here on the lobby
set before you move our asses downstairs
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on time for bed sores and thanks to
everyone in the back as ever marry kish
air Tay da Shaw Don moharrak anyone else
no that's it that's is happy don't give
anyone else credit we're out of here
next Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific we'll see
you and until then make sure you tune in
to gamespot com for all your video game
goodness I'm gonna go fix my tongue for
whatever all of this has happened to it
your take care see you next week